I thought that was my chair I think this
is my better side
[Music]
all right Anna what Drew you to the film
I wanted to work with you again yes it's
true it's true but in a very different
capacity like I knew as soon as I read
it that you and I were gonna have a
blast yeah this is uh my third
collaboration with the lovely day armas
this is actually the first time we get
along you know we've been adversaries
for the other films so finally her and I
actually get to work together like each
other a little bit more eventually
eventually we get there
oh
who are you CIA so Sadie she's this
incredible secret agent and she meets
Cole and there's something in Coal that
she's never seen before you know it's
very weird flimsy
Charming magnetic
irresistible magnificent well I was just
wondering if you wanted to um
yeah
go out sometime are you serious
there's something refreshingly honest
about Cole you know albeit a little
clumsy
I saw the rock but they have this really
nice meeting they have this great date
man then Sadie ghosts him and I don't
think Cole deserved it I mean he was
obviously a little too enthusiastic he
kind of couldn't read the room just a
little I bet she hasn't even seen your
text yeah yeah go to her I'm going to
London just a little but you know she
obviously had bigger fish to fry she had
a lot going on I wasn't working
awesome
there really are so many great action
set pieces whether it's the bus or the
plane or the rotating restaurant are you
ready wait for what no I'm not I'm
definitely not
[Music]
the scene in the restaurant was really
challenging because it was a really big
space yeah that was one of the few
scenes that we really got to have with
Adrian what the Romantic spot for our
first official date Adrian is such a
great energy on set he's so good he's so
funny I met Adrian in a very different
movie and all of the setting I see
Adrian with this fun stuff
French accent
what do you go for huh a fairy tale
fairy tales are for children
it's really really challenging I think
probably the most difficult scene
and of course I was like in distress
heels and yeah
the difficulty of you know once this
thing is gets out of control and starts
spinning faster and faster
yeah the gravity of the pressure it was
just really really hard you look amazing
in that dress
on YouTube wear more suits
I really do think this is something that
is going to be for everyone you know
because it does have this marriage and
comedy and action and romance and drama
I mean it checks all those boxes and
it's one of those movies that I grew up
on that I love dearly that that I just
don't see enough I feel like it is
relevant in today's world and honestly
how do people meet each other don't ask
me I can barely use my phone
I'm pretty sure there's a lot of texting
involved there are a lot of emojis Emoji
stuff doesn't count yes it does
hopefully for everyone out there who's
been ghosted it'll give them the belief
that maybe they were ghosted because the
person was a super spy I have never been
ghosted really it's not true I mean I
have my confidence especially if she's
the one who ghosted yeah no no she
didn't ghost me she just doesn't have an
international calling plan oh right an
international art curator doesn't have
an overseas cooling plan that's very
unusual
[Music]